[Musique]
retour sur le plateau avec adria
l'abissa lueur rien salut lionel comment
tu vas ça va très bien alors tu as
rencontré le binôme de nicolas jander
canaux côté comment allez vous très bien
merci on est ravis de vous accueillir
vous êtes conseiller départemental dans
le canton de altkirch votre binôme
sabine drexler vous l'avez rencontrée et
elle vous a baladés à peu près partout
en effet ce soir je vous emmène dans le
canton d'altkirch où j'ai pu rencontrer
sabine draxler nous partons donc pour le
sundgau un territoire plutôt méconnu
mais tout à fait attractifs vous allez y
découvrir le service solidarité
organisée par le conseil départemental
et une initiative plutôt surprenante des
frites fraîches médine ce nouveau
regarder des paysages très divers des
bords de l'ill au massif du jura
alsacien le canton d'altkirch compte 67
communes et 47 mille habitants un
territoire rural tout en contrastes
caractérisée par l'importance de
l'agriculture et la proximité de la
suisse une des problématiques de notre
territoire c'est le manque de réseau
routier ce problème là va faire qu'en
fait les industries on ne peut pas il se
projeter en fait dans un avenir qui sera
fait de l'installation d'industries et
donc ce qui va obliger les gens à partir
loin pour aller travailler donc nous
avons des gens qui partent sur mulhouse
ou alors surtout vers la région
frontalière on se rend compte que les
villages surtout au niveau de la vallée
de la largue du jura alsacien ce sont
des villages qui sont malheureusement en
train de se vider alors une manière de
pouvoir convaincre les gens de rester
dans le sundgau et pourquoi pas de leur
donner envie de venir s'y établir c'est
de le rendre attrayant par exemple
niveau de l'école une réflexion qui est
menée actuellement de notre territoire
et qui est intéressante c'est le
regroupement de communes autour d'une
d'un pôle scolaire unique
développer l'attractivité on s'y emploie
depuis longtemps à altkirch exemple
d'action publique réussie l'ancienne
caserne du quartier plessier qui
accueille maintenant aux entreprises et
services publics de proximité on y
trouve une antenne du conseil
départemental qui permet d'amener les
services départementaux au plus près des
habitants notamment au niveau de la
solidarité l'espace solidarité
altkirch est un
service qui regroupe plusieurs autres
pôles
d'activités au service de la population
la plus démunie on essaye de rester au
coeur des territoires pour apporter
vraiment un service au plus près des
personnes nous nous suivons les
personnes finalement 2 avant la
naissance jusqu'à la retraite et le pôle
gérontologique prend le relais le
service social gérontologique est un
service social pour les personnes
retraitées c'est à dire que le conseil
départemental offre aux personnes
retraitées un service social des
assistantes sociales qui sont
spécifiques aux personnes retraitées
territoire agricole la région d'altkirch
est aussi forte de ses agriculteurs
en faisant le tour en fait de plusieurs
exploitations d'un secteur je me suis
vraiment rendu compte d'un grand
dynamisme au niveau de nos jeunes
agriculteurs qui sont très innovant
voilà six ans que le magasin les champs
de lille propose en vente directe les
produits une trentaine d'agriculteurs de
la région est depuis quelques mois il
propose également la production de
jérémy figuères soutenue par le conseil
départemental
le jeune agriculteur de 23 ans a pu
investir et lancer les premières frites
fraîches medingo il faut la chercher une
activité un peu innovante est quelque
chose qui nous on se distingue des
autres producteurs et on a fait ce choix
parce que c'est on a en bio on est
nouveau sur le son marché et avec du
recul ça fait huit mois qu'on a qu'on a
commencé ce projet et on n'a que des que
des retombées positives on a un beau
chez du du personnel également n'a pu
investir dans du matériel une initiative
parmi d'autres qui permet d'assurer le
développement économique du territoire
dans le canton d'altkirch on n'a pas de
pétrole mais on a des idées
alors tout cas c'est appétissant vous
les avez goûté les frites melingo
absolument elles sont très bonnes c'est
une super idée si seulement voilà c'est
comme c'est ça qu'il faut pousser alors
le sumo c'est une vraie belle région
votre binôme dévoila difficile un petit
peu d'accès comment est-ce qu'on peut
rendre les choses et ce quoi là il y
aura un attractif vous êtes rendu compte
en regardant les images de ce très beau
reportage que on a la chance d'avoir
deux très beaux paysages en soit elle
très très variés une les contreforts du
jura alsacien
des rivières deschamps c'est 112
communes donc c'est un territoire très
rurale avec les avantages et les
inconvénients aussi de la ruralité et
donc pour le rendre encore plus
attractif et bien au niveau du conseil
départemental nous avons un outil qui
s'appelle les contrats de territoire de
vie qui permettent de soutenir les
projets aux dits structurants à dire
quelqu'un passe par vous et vous allez
l'accompagnait qui peut accompagner les
porteurs de projets effectivement si le
projet en question et structurant pour
le territoire
fm et votre binôme l'évoqué dans le
reportage des problèmes de réseau
routier qui peuvent dissuader les
entreprises de s'installer est-ce que
c'est difficile de faire venir des
entreprises dans le sundgau c'est pas
difficile mais c'est vrai que le réseau
routier n'est pas spécialement un atout
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire p
géographique 6,5 géographique on n'aura
jamais d'autoroute dans le sundgau
d'ailleurs on ne souhaiterait pas par
contre ce que l'on pourrait s qu'on
essaye d'obtenir c'est la fibre à le
développement du haut débit du très haut
débit sur tout le territoire
sundgauviens ça serait un atout
considérable pour le ce territoire rural
pour faire venir des entreprises dans le
cadre de pépinières d'entreprises
notamment des start up etc alors vous
l'a dit territoire rural rural comment
est-ce qu'on soutient les agriculteurs
qu'est ce qu'on met à disposition pour
les aider alors c'est important de les
soutenir parce que nos agriculteurs dans
leurs dans le sundgau c'est
essentiellement des producteurs laitiers
les éleveurs producteurs laitiers et qui
subissent actuellement une double crise
c'est-à-dire la crise dans un premier
temps du prix du lait c'est le marché
mondial les prix sont effondrés donc à
la fin ils sont pâtissent par définition
et puis la sécheresse c'est plus
conjoncturelle la sécheresse de cet été
qui fait que nos agriculteurs ont dû
taper d'aller dire dans le fourrage de
prévu pour cet hiver et donc à une
obligation de sur semi au mois de
septembre avec des coûts supplémentaires
et donc au niveau du conseil
départemental nous allons voir comment
on peut les aider par rapport à ces
coûts supplémentaires sachant que
parallèlement l'aide du département est
quand même conséquente puisqu'elle
s'élève j'ai pas les chiffres précis en
tête mais de l'ordre de 460 mille euros
du budget qui pensent qu'ils sont
consacrés donc aux aides aux
agriculteurs les l'aide à l'installation
des jeunes agriculteurs par exemple les
financements des études prospectives
les vous êtes vigilants ils ont besoin
d'elle vous intervenez ou en tout cas
ils peuvent venir parler avec vous et
vous analysez on est à l'écouté on est
tous moi ce que je sais avec sabine dhr
exr on s'était dit dès le départ on
place notre mandat sous le signe de la
proximité et donc on va au contact des
agriculteurs notamment cet été quand ils
ont eu ces problèmes et déjà les écouter
c'est déjà pas mal alors ça suffit pas
évidemment mais ensuite on regarde
ensemble comment on peut les aider au
mieux justement c'est z ça coûte de
l'argent et on connaît les difficultés
financières des collectivités alors vous
vous proposer de rassembler les communes
en fait de quoi s'agit-il
on a une petite particularité si vous
allez dans le sundgau 112 communes un
canton et demie aussi le canton de
dannemarie masse vaut maintenant tout
comme ils sont douze ans ces 112
communes c'est cette communauté de
communes d'accord pour soixante sept
mille habitants
on a vu tout à l'heure philippe richert
parler de la grande région sera plus
grande que la belgique plus grand des
sérieux au passage il faut la belgique
nous on est 112 communes sur un petit
territoire soixante sept mille habitants
7 comme comme avec une volonté de l'état
qui est actuellement en clair d'assécher
les finances des communes et donc ce que
je pense qu'il faudra faire de façon
intelligente et est en bonne
intelligence également avec tous les
partenaires c'est premièrement qu'il y
ait moins intercommunale intercall était
plus forte une seule comme comme à
l'échelle du territoire ça me paraîtrait
optimale
et puis il ya également la possibilité
de faire des communes nouvelles à qui
permettrait d'avoir peut-être moins de
communes pour avoir des moyens
supplémentaires et avec une
mutualisation optimale a été fait du
côté de sigolsheim avec kaysersberg par
un de vos collègues mais résolument à
l'egypte ait elle exactement quand les
spl et ça a l'air de plutôt bien marché
il faut juste la volonté en tout cas
vous semblait l'avoir descalso lui ment
voilà vous avez pris vos nouvelles
fonctions en avril 2015 il faut combien
de temps pour apprendre dit une année
pour apprendre et après une année pour
pour travailler alors certains glorieux
anciens m'ont dit qu'il fallait deux ou
trois mandats mais ce n'est pas du tout
dans cette perspective que je m'inscris
évidemment puisque avant de se présenter
on a eu un parcours on n'est pas venue à
la dernière minute deux semaines avant
les élections en disant vous votez votez
pour nous nous sommes les meilleurs on
était engagée déjà dans la vie
associative dans la vie politique on
exerçait d'autres mandats notamment à la
halle à communes d'altkirch en ce qui me
concerne et de durmenach en ce qui
concerne sabine draxler est également
vice président de la com com et donc
voilà on en a fait campagne on a
rencontré des gens pendant plusieurs
années c'est pas à la dernière minute
qu'on est venu donc on s'est mis petit à
petit dès avant l'élection dans la peau
du personnage et puis ensuite on
découvre effectivement les rouages de
cette belle administration qu'est le
conseil départemental et vous dites
c'est plus rapide que prévu finalement
c'est je mentirais en disant que j'ai
pris totalement et marc c'est pas vrai
mais en tout cas je pense que
le plus dur est fait voilà en tout cas
merci à vous nous habituer à sabine
dreclerc qui nous a ouvert les portes a
été plutôt sympa a été très sympa et
vous amener à peu près partout